this is my name of this is weird but I
love you Connor defeat them - Sparky all
good yeah he kind of said so [ __ ] them
up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
how's it going
hey guys do it good summer and John
Brennan I said are you doing good
[Music]
Pseudolus should go over I think in
London went to the London Tower with the
ground and raffia who and there's a
closely kind of Thrones and I clocked it
around and then to get to any [ __ ]
the crown jewels the line was like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
like this
[Laughter]
[Music]
but get out of there
we first got to
London with the rotor backwards from
what they're in the States
[Music]
Mike McGregor yeah so so our shouldn't
even be like the traditional oh yeah any
other type of okay horse you like the
luck your suit here's gonna be more like
the Asian mafia the thing is when you
get something that small yeah and the
pre which is looking like you have to
like you I'd say instead of something
that's gonna have enough detail to kind
of read as a horseshoe you know or
almost sing ah can shave your head just
kiddin yeah we catch our crab if you so
much as my divorce yeah I mean just my
opinion if you're looking at this is you
could have known you're in a horseshoe
or you gonna see a horseshoe or just a
matter of you know what's not said you
know what is use somewhere like yeah I'd
say just because of it's just one of
those things that's so gay I respect
that have something that you might
regret it Jenna's zero tattoos well just
do the goddamn now there's so intense
I'm almost relieved he's going to do it
it's cool man you slide I got it open
now
the next one over
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
yes I should
[Applause]
was there dr. William Lee wait there
who's barmy rear air blew the startup
called air you were fact that toady
Bobby's not seen fun oh yeah
was it one of our millionaires gonna
play me me me so there's nothing to do
for insulting no you can't fight no
gonna stick my head with that had you
looking away look
[Laughter]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
I love drinking problem I'm excited
before
crowd
check out mission complete boys
[Music]
[Applause]